hello everybody and welcome to the
second Python and pandas tutorial video
in our video series what we're talking
about in this video is some of the
basics of pandas as far as terminology
is concerned and basically what these
words actually mean what pandas is what
an object in pandas is and all this so
despite the fact that some people might
be frustrated with the fact that we're
not actually coding anything yet it's
imperative that you understand what a
data frame is what a series is what can
we do with them what are their
characteristics and also what can we do
with pandas what can we expect ourselves
to be able to do that way if we come
across a problem we can work around that
problem figure out much quicker
what is might even be going wrong so
it's just definitely essential that you
understand what these things are so with
that let's go ahead and get started so
the first thing that I want to talk
about is one of the most basic pandas
objects and that's a series so generally
you're going to see series and let me go
ahead and just make this multi-line
comment so you're going to see a series
and basically what a series is is
seriously is a one dimensional array and
it's much it's going to act a lot like
an umpire right so you can pass a series
through like as if it was an umpire
array and do numpy operations on it for
the most part there's some that are not
going to work but most of the operations
are going to work as if a series is an
umpire array so the other thing too is
you can put any data type in a series so
this means strings integers floats but
also any Python object right and other
things so any data type can go in there
so the hack ability of that is actually
quite large and maybe will go into that
at some point but you can put anything
in there just like you can put function
in a dictionary and you can do some
really cool stuff like that so anyway
well maybe hit on that later so again
it's just a one one-dimensional
um none title like array it's not really
an umpire array but it's much like an
umpire array and can be treated like an
umpire array you can put any data type
in there and you can also like it's an
umpire right you can do vectorize
operations and finally generally a
series is denoted with a lowercase s so
series equals s so generally what you'll
actually see is something more like this
s equals series bubble okay so that's
series
the next thing honestly series is not
too useful unless you like I want it
generally you're not using it you might
use it for intz I suppose in some floats
you'll probably use it and you might use
it for the vectorized operations but
generally what most people want pandas
for is not series they want it for the
following thing they want for data
frames now data frame is a
two-dimensional numpy like array and
again any data type can go through there
this is denoted with a lowercase D F so
a lot of times you see DF equals and the
data frame and all of that also I
wouldn't - D can sometimes be confusing
okay so two dimensional just means
there's only two dimensions but this
basically you can almost think of it as
like a table right any table is a two
dimensional thing right you don't have
three dimensions it's just a flat box so
a two-dimensional array you can have a
million rows and five columns okay so
that just sometimes people get confused
about what a dimension is so just trying
to clarify that so a data frame also
both of these the series even though
it's a one-dimensional numpy right still
can have a label right so it can still
you can still label that column so it
can have a name and a data set besides
just being serious right series can
still have a label
same thing with data for any
every column can have a label now and
then the rows generally the label for a
row is an index so here your index with
panels a lot as well
now index is basically what is all of
our data associated with I suppose is a
good way to put it so say you have a
bunch of data that's based on time so
you've got like maybe stock prices okay
and you've got open high/low clothes and
date you're probably going to index that
data by date not close I mean you could
do it by close if you want it but you're
probably to do it by date and you're
going to order it by date but you could
order it by clothes and you can index it
by clothes and order it by closing price
and all that you can do all kinds of
stuff so anyway the index is basically
what the data is associated with and you
can specify the index generally pandas
is going to say the first column is the
index but you can change that all you
want so now so basically I mean there's
other terms with pandas but these are
the terms that you definitely want to
understand you're going to see series
people talk about series you're going to
see data frame all the time and you're
gonna see index and indexing and all of
that so now what else can we do with
this stuff right so these are your
basically your objects okay and so what
can we do with a series in a data frame
and then series and data frames
well data frames have indexes what can
we do with that well we can we can do
slicing which basically just means you
know selecting data so if you take a
slice of a list for example you can take
element 25 - element 500 of that list
that's a slice of that list so you can
specify selector you can select specific
bits of data you can ring index which is
you can define redefine what the index
is you can order by that index and all
of that you also order by other columns
if you wanted to you can also move
columns slash reorganize
and you can do do mathematical
operations so on each row or on rows so
here you can do you could say I want
column 1 plus column 2 to be equal to
column 3 or you know like column 3 is
going to be column on this phone too
so you can do this very very quickly and
easily by row if you want to reference
prior rows referencing prior rows hard
but possible there are a few built-in
commands like difference and some other
ones there's also built-in moving
averages referred to as rolling means in
pandas and then also standard deviation
that's built in to pandas very simply
finally we have graphing so graphing it
uses matplotlib which is why I told you
you might want to go ahead and get
matplotlib graphing is built-in to
pandas and actually will a lot of times
import matplotlib for you you might not
have any idea that you're using that
plot lib but you are and graphing is
super simple you know what I mean by
that is with graphing you can basically
take your data frame you can load it
into matplotlib so if you have let's say
you've got a stock file
it's got date in a date stamp oh pretty
much whatever format date stamp open
high low close you can read that in and
say I want to graph that data frame and
it will graph that data frame and you
don't have to do anything else and that
is just really nice we matplotlib is is
a great module but if you've used more
fuoco from pandas to matplotlib
especially plotting date format stuff
you'll realize how much pandas does for
you i mean just the fact that it like
seems to it's a good word for it
intuitively plot some of the stuff that
you'll feed it it's very impressive so
you can easily do like histograms you
know bar charts and you can do like
linear charts line charts line graphs
all that kind of stuff you'll want to
really
neat stuff with matplotlib very quick
very easily with pandas so that's a
quick run-through of the terms that you
really need to understand right away you
need to understand what a series is what
you can do with the series basically you
can do a lot of stuff one thing I did
not really mention here it's like an
umpire array but also series and data
frames dictionary like so they can act
like dictionaries too this is also
dictionary like and what I mean by that
is you could say DF so most people are
like I said they're gonna say DF equals
de for an blah blah blah you could say
DF and then whatever the name of say
column one is you can reference it just
like that and that will be the whole
column and so it acts like a dictionary
you can do a lot of dictionary commands
with it and again just like you can feed
functions through dictionaries you can
feed a function through here and other
Python objects through here and so this
means you can do a lot of really quick
operations so even if you're not trying
to do vectorized calculations or really
super intense mathematics you can still
utilize the structure of pandas to do a
lot of quicker processing than you ever
thought you might so anyway we might
maybe after I'm done with the basics
I'll show some like pandas hacks because
you could do a lot of really really cool
stuff with this so anyways that's going
to include the second video in the next
video we'll be getting into some coding
so don't worry but it definitely is
necessary to understand what these are
what we can do with pandas and have a
general understanding of what these
datasets are so we kind of know what we
can and can't do so anyways if anybody
has any questions or comments feel free
to leave those in the section below as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all of the support subscriptions and
until next time